I know why we come to Italy as a lorry
and what do you get out of coming to
window I'm talking to you as a student
not only as interviewer this this
vehicle to talk to her or to excite
young people to interact with you
each year at the lindau meetings in
Germany young research has come together
to learn from Nobel Prize winners as
well as from each other I study what I
like to call the molecular basis of you
are what you eat
so I look at both how the food you eat
changes your gene expression and how the
genes that you have changed the way you
interact with food my research focuses
on the development of nanoparticles for
drug delivery and the reason that's
important is because we haven't got cues
yet for things like cancer and heart
disease and I want to try and make an
impact on that but there's much more to
the meetings in lindau than seeking
scientific collaboration they also
inspire discussion about wider questions
in science
most Nobel Prize medals a middle-aged or
elderly men only three women laureates
were present at Linda this year as a
female researcher I'm particularly
interested in meeting the female
laureates so a donor is someone I'm
particularly interested in meeting a
Dayani wanna know they'll prize for work
on the structure of the ribosome a
complex molecular machine found within
all living cells
so why the ribosome as opposed to any
other molecule that we didn't have the
structure for at the time I had the
least of what we don't understand very
very wrongly because it was interesting
because I found today I found an idea
how I can go on and found the
collaborator in what's plant it was
ready to listen to me although I was
known to be I was the crazy they stupid
village for whatever I couldn't care
less I because I sold it with we
advanced so when you first started
working on on the ribosomes that people
called you a dreamer yeah I I had the
perception you stand where you think so
to that the completely lopsided nature
of science in terms of the male-female
ratio in the older generation looks
completely different in the younger
generation yeah and I don't know whether
that is representative in most countries
of the students bodies and there or
whether it's what's been selected at let
them down yeah and for it for you
interesting I mean I think that I think
there's definitely you're right in the
the older generations maybe it's still
more weighted towards male you know
scientists but you know you come here to
Lindo and definitely you're right
there's it looks like 50/50 mix if not
maybe um a more positive selection a lot
of females now pushing into the sciences
good science you know a process that's
really good so maybe in the next sixty
five years we'll have more than three
female Lori yes I think the problem for
women in science isn't solved because
even though we're about 50/50
male-female in the young scientists here
as we progress through our careers more
women are dropping out than men so women
still aren't making it to the upper
tiers in the research world so I think
that we still have a long way to go to
get to equality for gender in science
the important thing that I've learned is
the the courage to tackle the big
problems a lot of the laureates have
addressed the fact that science doesn't
exist in isolation so we exist in the
world and therefore we have ethical and
social responsibilities for the things
that we can do with our science and I
think that's been a really important
theme and I'm glad to have had that
brought up and it's a fantastic
opportunity and one that I'm gonna
remember for a long time but I think the
other thing that's good is we can take
what we've learned back because only 650
something young science has got to be
here this year but there's so many young
scientists around the world but we can
take what we learn we learn and take it
back to to people in our country and
share it with them
so that's really cool
the beautiful bay above tree or Tree of
Life is an African icon the baobab fruit
contains four times the potassium of
banana three times the vitamin C of an
orange and twice the calcium of spinach
but the Bale Bob is an orphan science
has paid little attention to this tree
until now the African orphan crops
consortium is harnessing the power of
genetics for orphan crops the bail Bob
tree is the first of 101 plants to have
its genome sequence assembled and
annotated and the information will be
made available to all unrestricted where
millions of people are malnourished this
genetic data will help farmers provide
the food they need the genomes will
guide African plant breeders so they can
create crops that are higher yielding
water and nutrient use sufficient
resilient to climate change and full of
nutrition triggering a huge leap forward
for the diversity and sustainability of
the continents agriculture